[Musik]
universitätsspital zürich im letzten
februar marcel jahr 52 vor fünf monaten
diagnose brustkrebs vor drei tagen wird
er operiert
[Musik]
roland schwarzmann 46 diagnose ebenfalls
brustkrebs
er wird morgen operiert
cm
doch auch demokratisch
die beiden kennen sich teilen dasselbe
schicksal
alsfeld lassen aber draußen jetzt nicht
diskutieren wir mit stufe das buch
witzig
[Musik]
der letzte check vor der operation
morgen kommt roland schwarzmann und das
messer er und marcel jahn sind nur zwei
von insgesamt fast 1500 menschen die in
der schweiz nach offiziellen angaben
bisher an den folgen von asbest
unheilbar erkrankt sind
7 170 seien gestorben weitere 3000
werden in den nächsten jahren noch daran
sterben schätzt man
für viele kommt die diagnose ziemlich
überraschend er steht im sport aktiv sie
hat einen druck auf der brust über und
das hat sich für mich damit auch gar
nicht sie hat sich auch laune gibt hat
sich weder aus noch aus
celtic ausgestellten bin ich zum doktor
und deine welt macht die ortskirchen
gewählt wenn ich noch ein
besprechungszimmer wert band gemacht und
das habe ich sofort gesehen dass da mit
den einzahlungen bis überhaupt nicht
stimmt allerdings wusste der vater von
drei kindern sofort was das zu bedeuten
hatte aufgrund vom umwelt wenig trauen
also die vermieter nicht schafft muss
ins niedrigen aufgewachsen hat doch
david falke mit asbest und jedes mal war
nicht aus es kommt gar nicht gewusst
dass ich als jugendlicher docomo
intensiv mit us-pass geschafft hat sich
für mich natürlich so schlimmes
befürchtet entwickelt und grant dass der
hund einfach der newa chaotisch auch
marcel jahn wurde schlagartig mit seiner
vergangenheit konfrontiert
logan arzt hat mir vom eine messe terium
geld als möglichkeit
und dann hat er das motto special runter
weil mir war und dann ist mir natürlich
dazu hans gebaut werden ist linksseitig
begonnen aber tritt fabrik aufgewachsen
und wirklich meine die unmittelbaren
euren achte produktion mit asbest der hc
lugano 2
das ist eine fähigkeit ich log sie und
dann habe ich mich auf eine befassung
mit dem messer telio und überall wo man
also mein körper den ärzten ist die der
studie peter terium ich brauchte ich
immer als bester fest hitzebeständig
widerstandsfähig und vor allem billig
als best das war der wunderbar stoff des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
der große tag ist da die expo 64
eröffnet sechs monate lang wird uns die
landesausstellung in lausanne zu land
und zu wasser spiegel der heimat sein
allein an dieser expo wurden 19.000
quadratmeter als best format
[Musik]
aber nicht nur das
als best zement hat die baubranche
revolutioniert endlich waren
einfamilienhäuser auch für untere
einkommensklassen erschwinglich neue
blumenkisten verschönerten den alltag
der schweizer hausfrauen oder dienten
sogar als bücherregal kurz der aufbruch
in die moderne hatte begonnen
[Applaus]
produzent des wunder baustoffs die
eternit in niederurnen
der journalist werner katrina hat die
geschichte von eternit 1985 in seinem
buch nachgezeichnet
das möchte ich eigentlich die faser des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
das hat ein unglaublicher aufschwung
kino gelockt expo 460 dass ich etwas
pech zimmer hindu stelle ich sie und hat
nämlich seit das ist nicht gut
webseite sich modern und nachhaltig den
einfach der hase vor
der erste fonds muss man sein ganzes für
rico und in dem sie nicht als bester
exemplarische sache ich meine wir viel
sache die mir jetzt welt setzte dominik
rüstet was ist in swensk aldi handy
senior all die strahler vor dem
bildschirm das wussten wir nicht dass
grund irgendwann geht's erfolg für das
ganze ersparte und aspekt ist eigentlich
eine exemplarische fahrverhältnisse man
zuerst der vorteil hat und nach der
statischen auf ihrer co sind die asbest
euphorie beginnt anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts im minen in kanada und
südafrika wird ein großer stein abgebaut
daraus lässt sich die feuerfeste wunder
faserhersteller in säcke verpackt wird
das best in die ganze welt exportiert
in der schweiz haben sich 1903 ein paar
unternehmer ein patent das ihnen ein
millionenvermögen bescheren wird
in niederurnen wird die firma internet
gegründet und produziert dachziegel mit
einem baustoff von dem man bisher nur
träumen konnte vermischt mit zement ist
asbest nämlich widerstandsfähig rostfrei
und dazu noch formbar
das geschäft floriert die nachfrage
steigt sogar der könig von siam bestellt
ganze schiffsladungen voller für die
bedachung seiner lust häuser
[Musik]
1920 steigt ernst schmidt ein iba
eternit ein und beginnt mit der
expansion ins ausland
[Musik]
1935 übernimmt sein sohn max unter ihm
wird damit zu einem internationalen
konzern mit fabriken in vielen ländern
und zur nummer zwei auf dem weltmarkt
in spitzenzeiten anfangs der 70er jahre
verarbeitet man allein in niederurnen
20.000 tonnen asbest pro jahr
der umsatz der schweizer thermit gruppe
beträgt 2 milliarden franken pro jahr
max schmidheiny behauptet zeit seines
lebens mit der neat platten seien
ungefährlich sich zu wehren aus
speziellen dokumentation thema kunden im
internet
aber dieser stunde vor dem punkt also
internet produziert ist und die ganz
könige die mienen der transport der
lieferung der erste schritt von der
produktion durch transport macht gleich
frei oder das ist aber gab es in amerika
schon früher hinweise auf die gefahr
1918 weigerte sich nämlich eine
versicherung für asbest arbeiter
lebensversicherungen abzuschließen wegen
des zu hohen risikos die ersten fälle
von lungen- oder brustkrebs werden in
den 30er jahren wissenschaftlich
beschrieben
und dass solche unsichtbaren hier mehr
tausendfach vergrößerten asbestfasern
krebs verursachen können wird 1964
bewiesen und zwar durch den
international berühmten asbest forscher
professor willi kopf ein starker kontakt
mit asbest während eines einzigen monats
im leben kann jahrzehnte später mesut
eli um krebs verursachen und das
lungenkrebsrisiko verdoppeln
das ist kein verdacht sondern sicheres
wissen sagt serikow in der schweiz wird
diese warnung ignoriert die euphorie
geht weiter über albert eternit in rauen
mengen eingesetzt
stefan schmid eni hat einmal
ausgerechnet es würden nur gerade 100
jahre dauern bis die ganze schweiz mit
eternit platten zugedeckt wäre
[Musik]
marcel jahn hat in dieser zeit neben der
eternit fabriken niederurnen gewohnt
jetzt 35 jahre später zeigen sich die
folgen die hand auch nix los als kind
mit erhöhter port ethernet verbraucher
versorgt im garten hühner oder mir hat
mal zum wichtigkeit ist alles eine
blumenschale janica was das heißt haben
sie nie irgendwie gewarnt wurde und
schlafzimmer veranstalter für die 50
metern höchsten produktionskosten auch
geschafft hat und aus verarbeitet hat
also gut natürlich waren sehen gott wenn
ich mir das überlegt walter weder chef
der thoraxchirurgie am
universitätsspital zürich hat marcel
laboriert momentan mit gurten
das ist einfach verschiedene noch ganz
ganz große operationen und erste seite
noch 56 tag trotzdem jeden tag wirklich
wesentlich besser weiter weder und seine
kollegen sind führend bei der behandlung
von mesut allien also brustfell krebs es
ist die krebsart die es 20 bis 40 jahre
später ausbricht und eigentlich immer
auf asbest zurückgeführt werden kann
bisher sind in der schweiz nach
offizieller statistik 770 menschen daran
gestorben
fachleute gehen davon aus dass in der
nächsten zeit nochmals bis zu 100
menschen pro jahr an einem eso telio
erkranken werden
also mir könnt auch für deine zahlen
also mehr erreichte damit eine zahlen
dass der kongress wertet immer werte
berechnet dass das navi dazu erlebt und
dom ist im moment aber noch sehr
handlich großes interesse drei
verschiedene behandlungskonzept dazu
bitte dass wir jetzt machen wie ich nur
ein schritt für gewitter entwickelt das
wird laufend überdacht und verbessert
und vielleicht werde ich später andere
behandlungsansatz gemacht habe intensiv
geforscht und dass wir druck macht will
man einfach gesagt dass ich das problem
wonach es zu beruhigen
unbehandelt sterben die meisten
patienten innerhalb von anderthalb
jahren mit dem neue behandlungskonzepte
zieht einige jahre mache gewinnt gibt es
zumindest potenziell chance dass der
eine oder andere patient lang zieht über
frei wird und dass man das so genannte
mittlere über bleibe eine zwei bis drei
jahren immer noch eine düstere prognose
wenn man bedenkt dass roland schwarz man
als 14-jähriger während ferienjobs nur
gerade ein paar wochen dem asbest
ausgesetzt war
morgen wird ihm der rechten lungenflügel
bloß ein teil des zwerchfells und des
herz beutels entfernt eine lange und
schwierige operation hat er nicht mit
dem schicksal hat mich damals wirkt
wenig besser küsst
für mich ist ganz sicher dass der lytro
den stuhl verschafft und rangiere mit
schafft die hand nimmt ist die hand der
media ag sie haben freute sich bis zur
heutigen so denkt man natürlich so
roland schwarz man hatte wohl einfach
pech 1972 als er solche platten schliff
wurden in amerika schon erste prozesse
angestrengt oder erst zwei jahre später
nämlich als der von schmidt heini die
eternit von seinem vater übernimmt wird
die als best gefahr in der schweiz ernst
genommen sie für mich jetzt auf die
jungen besitzer damals dass stephan
schmidheiny wo das gamepad und meri
interview geht zu den themen und hat
einfach zeit das ganze ist irgendwie
todkrank obwohl das produkt noch
praktisch mit kriegen als baskets mit
dem star ich muss uns aus dem
zwar werden auch in niederurnen erst
1976 absauganlagen installiert aber der
ausstieg aus dem asbest wird
vorangetrieben
auf hochtouren wird nach einem
ersatzstoff gesucht der heutige
geschäftsführer an das heute hat diese
phase hautnah miterlebt
internet hat es angefangen bei 906 kurve
und es hat die die tastatur ist nicht
das letzte produkt umgestellt hat die
hauptteile 80er jahre umgestellt wurde
das ist eine gewaltige prozess sie das
hat zuerst bedeutet dass mir alle
handelsplätze wissmann hat keinen wunsch
möglichst staubfrei markt
der inhalt ein umstellen dann hat man
erlebnisse sage dass mir das rohstoff
während und gleichzeitig ist das ganze
in der öffentlichkeit das thema ob sie
mannheim fiel müsse schafe mitte medien
wir sehen zur mit der gewerkschaft
nachdem die firma auf kunstfasern
umgestellt hatte steht stephan
schmidheiny sukzessive aus der internet
aus mit der vergangenheit will heute
nichts mehr zu tun haben
meine situation sagen meine täter nicht
in riesige machen eine millione renditen
und umsatz erwirtschaftet das ist das
ist alles wieder in betrieb eine flosse
und für folge fürchten was ich da
gemacht oder wer die stadt zustande
finde ich einfach nicht weg befindet
verursachen
förster und verantwortung
stephan schmitter nie hat sich letztmals
2004 im schweizer fernsehen so als best
geäußert heute will er keine interviews
mehr geben
es war sicher nicht alles richtig und
vor allem wenn man die dinge aus
heutiger sicht beurteilt wo man viel
mehr weiß wo man ganz andere maßstäbe
anlegt ich habe ich wiederhole ich habe
das getan was mir möglich und zumutbar
war was mir bekannt war was ich
überhaupt durchsetzen konnte und ich
habe damit da auch heute noch ein gutes
gewissen modernen unternahm athen
ethisch sozial wichtig und dann war da
noch nicht so viel post hat man hat
einiges grüßt und ich finde dass wir den
internet verantwortung möglich gut aus
ganz bitter zu einer großzügigkeit will
dadurch wirklich deutsche verantwortung
weil maximilian i
angestellt war erhält er keine super
leistungen für ihn zahlt also nur die
krankenkasse später allenfalls die ev
darum hat der stephan schmidheiny einem
brief geschrieben die antwort weil doch
eher nicht und für solche
geschäftsrisiken sei man nicht mehr
zuständig diese seinem gespräch mit
metro vertretern
marcell jansen doch bei der neuen
ethernet um finanzielle unterstützung
bitten
unter den neuen eigentümern geblieben
ist geschäftsführer anders holte die
neue firma sagt er zahle für die folgen
der asbest katastrophe immer noch sehr
viel geld
diese vergangenheit
dieser service platzproblem leidet das
wird kosten abdeckt und der neue
aktionen finanziert da sind sofern mit
dass mit dem viele höhere prämien zahlen
sogar für zu dick von personenschäden
bei 400 gramm co pro jahr zahlen mehr
aufgrund füßen vergangenheit das hat der
neue rational mit gekauft dort holte
sind 45 ehemalige eternit arbeiter an
krebs bereits gestorben 65 leiden an
asbestose was man nicht genau weiß ist
was aus den 2500 fremdarbeitern geworden
ist wie früher bei eternit gearbeitet
haben
viele von ihnen sind nach italien
zurückgekehrt und in der zwischenzeit
verstorben wie viele leute aus niederen
sonst noch betroffen sind ist nicht
bekannt
dorfarzt martin wendel weiß jedoch er
hat die folgen von asbest im nächsten
umfeld erlebt
[Musik]
die nicht reden der kollege oder
ludendorff osten auch bedürfen erfolge
von asbest exposition frieren irgend
einmal stocker hat marcel jahn und
roland schwarz warnt sind zwei von ihnen
die krankheit hat sie zusammengeführt
nur 50 meter voneinander entfernt sind
sie mit asbest in kontakt gekommen
es war vor mehr als 35 jahren und jetzt
fünf wochen nach der operation
wie geht es ihnen dankbar sind die
wochen bis zur hat und es gab mir nichts
ich bin ziemlich gut
wie geht es julien nach der kur ich bin
schwach
ich bin langsam ich merke ich komplett
die in europa mitgesungen für mich sehr
mit der post im das elixier der basis
nämlich total mögen und ich bin verrückt
was der special guest hat das trifft
mich sehr aber und vor allem was ich
sage meine familie sehr viel mit 30
befindet hat sehr viel mit was die
beiden damals noch nicht wissen die
anschließende bestrahlung wird noch viel
härter beide nehmen nochmals sechs kilo
ab und können das bett für längere zeit
nicht mehr verlassen
das asbest problem ist aber bei weitem
nicht nur ein internet problem es geht
weit über die grenzen von niederurnen
hinaus die hätte 1% vom asbest in der
schweiz ungefähr verbraucht aber sie hat
zehn prozent von deiner kranke kaka also
andré sbb und andere handy eigentlich
größere größer krankheitsdauer biete
sich nicht die relativiere ich möchte
ich gerne mache aber nur zum sicher ganz
sehr breit genutzt die phase als best
verbindungen kamen früher in über 3000
produkten vor
topflappen oder feuerfeste untersätze im
haushalt vor schutzanzüge asbestos ist
das griechische wort für unzerstörbar
sprits asbest gilt auch dem bau darum
als wundermittel sei es als brandschutz
wärme oder elektro isolation gebraucht
wird es auch für bremse oder kupplungs
belege oder für die isolation von
eisenbahn war wie viele gebäude in der
schweiz in der euphorie so isoliert
wurden weiß heute niemand mehr erkannt
dass ich wirklich die ihr wunderbar
substanz und es gibt nur neues live mit
der substanz und ohne die firmen
überleben oder und dass ich sicher
reiner form innerhalb vorwirft das mit
bedeutung von ihrer substanz total
überschätzt hat und durch das hat sich
natürlich der eu stieg verzögerung
bildend wirtschaft gefangen hat druck
machen und seite nicht einfach jetzt vor
allem der ruf der anruf stiegen und wie
das abläuft hat sich das über jahre ja
insgesamt über mehr als 25 jahre hinweg
zogen und hätte dazu geführt dass 25
jahren arbeiten weiterhin schwer
geschädigt worden sind und jetzt ein
nächsten jahre werden tribut zollen
für diese leute setzte er sich ein
der lungenspezialist hat sich vor ein
paar jahren mit anwälten zusammen getan
und die vereinigung für asbest opfer
gegründet denn viele dieser leute fühlen
sich allein gelassen haben operationen
hinter sich und nicht mehr lange zu
leben
[Musik]
mit spritzer sprechen
mit dem special
dieburg spritzt dann die eine mausgraue
unter anderem ausgedacht beruflich habe
die ppc dazu natürliches 80er jahren tut
ihnen unter wenigsten also du dich
natürlich eine 12 jahre und musste die
ins krimi und jeder wenige tausend
absagen
und wirklich zu sehen
viele hier sind die den 60er 70er jahren
mit asbest in kontakt gekommen aber auch
in den 80er jahren als er schon
schutzvorschriften der suva gab wurden
diese oft nicht eingehalten
die sendung kassensturz deckt 1985 auf
wir haben uns umgeschaut
zum beispiel auf einem bauplatz ein
rundgang ergab noch immer wird eternit
so gesagt dass gefährlicher staub
entsteht ausgerechnet auf dem dach der
zürcher eternit arbeitete eine
dachdeckerfirma mit falschen gerät diese
fotos aufgenommen von einem
gewerkschaftssekretär der uns begleitete
zeigen der mann steht mitten im
asbesthaltigen staub ein anderes
beispiel wo viel mit asbest gearbeitet
wird beim auswechseln von bremsbelägen
in der garage nach wie vor ist ein
großer teil der bremsbeläge asbesthaltig
zum schutz der arbeiter gäbe ist zwar
spezielle absauganlagen doch vielerorts
wird trotzdem noch so gearbeitet
[Applaus]
bei der sbb auch hier gelangt als best
in die luft und zwar bei den revisionen
jener eisenbahnwagen die zur isolation
zwecken mit asbest ausgeräumt wurden die
arbeiter müssen wegen des staubs in
spezialanzügen und mit masken arbeiten
doch wir hörten die ausrüstung behindere
so stark dass sie nicht immer gebraucht
werden können auf die schlechte
einhaltung der sicherheitsvorschriften
angesprochen behauptete damals der
zuständige super arzt rudolf schütz im
gespräch aber immer noch man hätte das
problem im griff
die arbeitgeber würden genügend
informiert ich kann mich mit dem gast
und romani ite hat und er hat mir
erzählt dass bmw 15 super g im betrieb
gesetzt und das die sich für das
möglichen interessiert hätte aber das
noch keinen imiev seite gefährlich aus
dass sie schwanger sind die
bremstrommeln extraklasse
es ist möglich dass wir das im garage
stahlberg seite außerdem arbeiten
sondern sich vorgesetzte firma selber
rechteinhaber von karissa darin habe es
ist möglich als 1000 mit büro hätten
hättens ganz sicher zeit bei der super
sind alle industriearbeiter gegen unfall
und krankheit versichert
sie muss die sicherheit am arbeitsplatz
kontrollieren und schutzmaßnahmen
erlassen
aber die super stand immer wieder in der
kritik der kassensturz 1988
schon früher hat er die suva hunderte
von asbest arbeitern im stich gelassen
sie hatte als best firmen nicht dazu
verpflichtet sich zu melden
deshalb war der so war noch 1975 nur
jeder vierte asbest arbeiter registriert
1978 behauptete die suva dann sie
kontrolliere jetzt 90 prozent aller
asbest arbeiter tatsächlich waren es
auch dann höchstens 60 prozent
weil die so war keine meldepflicht
einführte musste die suva auch nicht wie
lange das besonders gefährliche spritzen
von asbest praktiziert wurde
so behauptete die suva seit 1973 aber
niemand mehr in der schweiz asbest
gespritzt
tatsächlich aber hat eine der grössten
sprits firmen noch bis 1976 gespritzt
ohne kontrolle durch die suva die super
habe über die asbest gefahr zu lange zu
wenig informiert und die betriebe nur
punktuell kontrolliert so lauten die
vorwürfe noch heute doch super arzt
rudolf schütz wird keine stellung mehr
nehmen für ihn antwortet manfred brümmer
pressesprecher bei der suva die
kontrollen der super waren sehr intensiv
sie waren sehr konsequent macht auch
konsequent eingegriffen
aber sie können nicht flächendeckend um
permanent sein
auf der anderen seite muss man sehen
dass die verantwortung in erster linie
für gesundheitsschutz von den
mitarbeitern beim arbeitgeber liegt und
dann wenn die suva nicht da ist und bei
der tür raus ist bleibt immer noch die
verantwortung des arbeitgebers die super
schiebt den schwarzen peter an die
betriebe zurück
die spd hat fast 4000 waggons mit sprit
asbest isoliert von den betroffenen 80
arbeitern sind bereits 50 gestorben
zum umgang mit asbest und zur einhaltung
von sicherheitsvorschriften damals mag
man sich bei der sbb heute nicht mehr
äußern
man habe vor einem jahr informiert das
müsse reichen so ihre antwort aus der
presseabteilung der schweizerischen
bundesbahnen auch die abb hat einer
space problem in amerika offerierte man
für sammelklagen der asbest opfer gegen
die abb tochter com basten engineering
1,4 milliarden dollar
die 21 schweizer opfer aber gehen leer
aus
dabei hatte die abb ihre dampfturbinen
in der produktion jahrelang mit
gefährlichen asbest tüchern umwickelt
erst in den späten 80er jahren hat man
auf ungefährliche kunstfasern umgestellt
die verantwortung dafür sieht man jedoch
elegant wieder an die suva zurück es ist
so dass mir im leben des kita mit der
suva masse gemacht hat so klar zeigt
dass die starren grenzwert sind also
technischen und medizin standpunkte sind
die crm maßnahmen nötig sie aus der
heutigen sicht sind erst recht keine
fehler passiert im nachhinein könne
sicheres mehr für die mitarbeit in der
alles gemacht hat um sie vor dass bosch
die wirkliche schütze der hand sämtliche
super vorschriften ricotta die hand so
widmann das könnte aus heutigem
zeitpunkt die urteile entsprachen die
schussabgabe der schwarze peter geht
also wieder an die super zurück klar wer
hätte denn sonst über die aus best
gefahr bescheid wissen sollten super
präsident franz steinegger gibt zu das
problem unterschätzt netz eigentlich nur
unter dem gesichtspunkt voraus bis klose
auch glück dass so eine steuer blum eine
behandlung und erst aufgrund vor
amerikanischen untersuche der sechziger
siebziger merkt dass sony mit krebs
erregend da muss ich sagen ist es
aussehe großraum sehr schnell und
erkannt wurde
man hätte neue gesetz das eigentlich
menschen sprit aus passion im erkennen
aufwand war aber im nachhinein muss
weshalb der mann hat das car show jeder
40-50 york misst
ab den 60er jahren zumindest hätte man
es wissen können
aber die diskussion in den medien nützt
wenig der ausstieg erfolgt sehr langsam
noch 1981 findet dass der bundesrat
nicht nötig ein asbest verbot zu
erlassen
erst 1989 also nochmals acht jahre
später ist die schweiz sei für diesen
schritt bis 1995 gelten noch
ausnahmebestimmungen erst dann ist das
best verboten wieso eigentlich so spät
thomas zeltner vom bundesamt für
gesundheit
als bester von einer typischen stoffe
wie schmid sieht gemerkt hätte ich
einfach umgefallen auch das frisch und
tatsächlich lange zeit braucht bis man
vor der priester statik eine besondere
zeit bis zu dem ausmaß von einer
scheiterte gekostet wie klassisch und
tatsächlich beim sparen in seiner jüngst
allerdings gar nicht möglich so belecker
zurück zur generalversammlung der asbest
opfer ein langer langer ausstieg der
viele zu viele opfer forderte
weil niemand wirklich den überblick
hatte wo aus best überall verwendet
wurde
wissen viele opfer gar nicht dass sie an
den folgen von asbest erkrankt sind
dunkelziffer mein vater zum beispiel
jetzt in den sechziger und siebziger
jahre mitgearbeitet so buchautor hat
anscheinend trotzdem gereicht hat rtl ii
um bekommen
vor zwei jahren ist vor einem jahr
gestorben und ich würde sagen klagen los
gestorben also der erscheint nirgends
meines wissens nirgends in einer
statistik die so etwas richtig ist es
sind die werden die fälle gar nicht
erfasst
die höhe richtig oder also ihr vater der
geht zum arzt dieser arzt behandelt ihn
stellt die diagnose und konnten nie auf
die idee dass hier ein zusammenhang mit
seinem beruf oder mit seiner arbeits
firma bestehen könnte oder er meldet
dass der suva nicht so weiß die super
von diesem fall nichts die super spricht
von bisher 7 170 als besten was sagt
karl klingler
zu dieser zahl einfach dir wo sie
tatsächlich
ich glaube dass ich schreibe nämlich
zahl aber auf der anderen seite die zur
dunkelziffer
ich würde sagen dass ich wahrscheinlich
der faktor 5 wurde ich dass es mir
schätzt ungefähr 33 uhr hat die musik
müssten sie aufgrund von der
hochrechnung mir gemacht hat
meeresschützer ungefähr 0 tägliche zahl
normalwerten brisant dass man nicht mehr
darüber hört denn wir wussten ja dass
sterbefällen pro hotel in dem berufsfeld
apps im moment ja 90 prozent vor allem
todesfall mit der berufskrankheiten
ausmachen bitte suva und die zahl wird
weiter steigen
und da werden fast alle der nächsten
zeit bis 15 jahren währt nur mit der
problematik bist du die super korrigiert
nach unten gibt aber zu also meine
situation macht über 60 prozent aller
todesfälle bei berufskrankheiten los und
die anzahl der 50 im jahren fand im
moment werde besser terium versucht
etwas mehr als die hälfte vor der
prozess krankheit des italian
todesfällen richtig die asbest
katastrophe kostet die suva aber schon
jetzt millionen
seit dem ersten aus berufskrankheit
anerkannten fallen 19 39 hat die super
für etwa rund 1500 patienten insgesamt
mehr als 53 millionen franken
leistungen ausgezahlt so viel zu den
opfern
doch die asbest katastrophe hat noch
weitere folgen
zehntausende von asbesthaltigen gebäuden
müssen saniert werden
spritzer asbest bröckelt ziemlich
schnell und ist dann besonders
gefährlich viele turnhallen schwimmbäder
und öffentliche gebäude wurden so
isoliert seit den 80er jahren werden sie
mit großem aufwand und unter strengsten
sicherheitsbedingungen sukzessive
saniert
prominentes beispiel der flughafen
zürich 150000 franken kostete hier die
entfernung von 1000 quadratmeter sprits
asbest und es ist noch lange nicht
ausgestanden
die meisten hausbesitzer wissen gar
nicht dass in ihrem haus asbest verbaut
wurde
und selbst wenn sie es wissen müssen sie
erst sanieren wenn sie einen umbau
planen
alle listen über als best haltige
gebäude die hier erstellt wurden sind
unvollständig und es gibt auch keine
frist bis wann die sanierung zu erfolgen
hat es gibt keine sanierungspflicht in
der schweiz sondern es ist wirklich die
sache der immobilienbesitzer die sich
auch an kantonale fach kantonale
fachstellen wenden können
für rat und unterstützung dann zu sehen
ob er eine gefährdung besteht oder nicht
das ist die rücklichter sich sie mehr
unter druck
süße besitzer sagte der wirt krise
theater veranstaltet mit einer
schutzmaßnahme wo die sanierte
kommentieren fährt war und ich glaube
dass ich mich zu verstrickte dass die
schutzmaßnahmen entropa werde ich eine
völlig ausschließen dass es irgendwann
notenstufe geht wo mein team traf es
nicht und entweder das macht oder ein
mitarbeiter findet wo es lästig ist die
notwendige schutzmaßnahmen todestag des
das habe nie völlig ausschließen aber
ich muss sagen dass wir da raus zu und
es auf der bereiche aber selbst
unternehmen die glauben ihre sanierung
bereits hinter sich zu haben erleben
böse überraschungen vor ein paar monaten
beispielsweise musste der globus in
zürich wegen asbest emission
vorübergehend geschlossen werden
überraschend ist vor allem dass ruse als
asbestfrei gilt also sie haben schon
früher magnas selbst als bei stadt und
das hat sich als negatives oder wie also
in der 80er jahren mit millionenaufwand
das muss rasch saniert und da sind
mäßiger wiederhold stattgefunden und das
haus gilt offiziell als pesch frei
übrigens keine ausnahme auch der st
galler rathaus und das westschweizer
fernsehen waren kürzlich wegen asbest
emissionen geschlossen
und dann gibt es noch einen fall bei dem
man gar nicht auf die idee kommt dass er
etwas mit asbest zu tun haben könnte
[Musik]
die arbeitszeiten sind sind ohne
fastpath dem staub effektiver russische
manhattans breitet hat so wird das
zumindest vor der amerikanische kollege
zählt und wie wird das die exposition
wurde ein
dazu führt das sollte die patientin
meteo mit wickelt das ist im moment
unklar
zurück zu den opfern in der schweiz
erstmals haben diese drei anwälte nun im
namen von betroffenen klagen gegen
verschiedene betriebe eingereicht das
bundesamt für gesundheit befürwortet
diese prozesse bei mir ist jetzt ein
musterprozess nach erwiesen
kursverhalten von der industrie hier
wenn dem so wäre es laut industrie mit
einem spezifischen v zahlen und die
spezifisch frau wird sich aber auch die
sofort generalisieren
und den muss man eine generelle lösung
die klage werde klar ich vor der frage
führen ohne größere kinder immer also im
interesse von der firma oder das
eigentlich mag lite wird das verfaulte
da unser servicecenter für grad steigen
in kreisform verhaltet euch so ist
definitiv
heute muss jedes opfer einzeln klagen
karl kling fordert eine umfassende
lösung für alle opfer gemeinsam mit 1 10
die problematik aufarbeiter und soll vor
allem ruhige dass die lytro betroffen
sind woran sind oder wo in zukunft noch
rang gewertet werden dass dir zu
mindestens zu einer minimalen eine
kleine gämsen grund dass man sich mit
einer lüge entschuldigt dass er so etwas
passiert ist und dass man merkt dass die
leute nach ein finanziell zwischen stuhl
und ein
diejenigen unter ihnen die in einem
industriebetrieb angestellt waren als
sie mit asbest in kontakt kamen erhalten
von der suva eine 80 prozent rente
ausbezahlt
besonders schwierig ist die situation
aber dann wenn die suva nicht zuständig
ist sei es weil jemand selbstständig
erwerbende war oder weil jemand einfach
in der nähe einer fabrik gewohnt hat wie
marcel i an
dann gibt es höchstens eine iv-rente
einen schadenersatzanspruch kann er
nicht mehr geltend machen obwohl ihm in
der zwischenzeit schon kosten von
mehreren zehntausend franken entstanden
sind
[Musik]
die juristisch verpflichtet ist ganz
komisch
es gibt es eine regel ich maximal 24
jährig nach exposition das heißt also
weitaus bessere gemein körperlos im von
dana zajac bis machen und die 2 ich
danke dass das 340 yoga bis merkel davor
ich natürlich als lebensfremd und absurd
karlinger findet eine solche
verjährungsfrist im fall von asbest
unhaltbar los geht's bei uns quasi auf
ebene der gerichte abläuft und wir
versuchen das eidgenössische berichte
versicherungsgericht davon zu überzeugen
dass diese verjährungsfrist nicht gilt
wurde in jedem anderen land politisch
aufgehoben da sind ist ein politiker
aufgestanden ins parlament gegangen hat
gesagt hör zu
das kann doch nicht sein dass eine
krankheit jedoch 20 bis 40 jahren aus
bricht nach zehn jahren verjährt sein
muss wir dürfen dieses gesetz nicht so
belasten wir müssen das aufheben
zwei interpellationen im national- und
ständerat
sie forderten dass die opfer besser
behandelt werden wurden vom bundesrat
mit formaljuristischen begründungen
abgeschmettert alles in allem müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass die regierung die
eigene regierung nicht bereit ist in den
nächsten jahren dieses thema irgendwie
aufzuarbeiten
neben allen persönlichem leid haben die
leute hier oft auch massive finanzielle
probleme
für härtefälle könnte man einen fonds
einrichten hört man immer wieder
ich persönlich finde wenn also bedürfnis
ist und wenn es einfach so verrät oder
mehr stimmrechte vector aerospace dass
man viel komfort macht für dich also
absolut richtig und fair finde aber wer
soll zahlen der bund oder die wirtschaft
ich finde es schwierig wenn der staat
immer mit vorsicht quasi versucht risiko
wird industrie geld quasi überstülpte
narita wie abstrakt wenn bisher chance
der schweiz ist tatsächlich
entschädigung durch die industrie sechs
im einzel oder wenn eine in zürich und
darunter dass ich ja der hilfe kostet
ihn als kritisch dass die betroffenen
die strikte regelung etwas konfus
einfacher
gerade global nichts machen das mit
einem fall diskutieren und wieder
beginnt der schwarze peter spiel wäre
stephan schmidheiny mehrfacher millionär
und ehemalige eternit besitzer gewillt
sich an einem solchen fonds zu
beteiligen wenn die anderen mitmachen
vielleicht doch heißt es hinter
vorgehaltener hand und die sbb der
schweizer betrieb der meisten tote zu
beklagen hat wäre die sbb gewählt sich
zu beteiligen
die abb würde nichts bezahlen
dafür habe man einen eigenen fonds der
sogenannte unterstützungsfonds bei
henriques richtet 19 24 jetzt bereits
und dessen helfer mitarbeitende
ehemalige mitarbeitende verwandte wo
aufgrund von einem unfall oder krankheit
in der notsituation kümmert finanziell
zu unterstützen und sich endlich wird
immer wenn in zusammenhang mit asbest
aus arizona traktiert sehr sehr genau
prüfe atomkraftwerke bis jetzt wo man
aus dem fall zahlt eon in almelo kai
völker
einzig die neue internet scheint keine
berührungsängste zu haben
theoretisch möglich ist alles ich denke
es ist schwer oder schwierig nur eine
einzige krankheit oder einzige
schwierigkeit umsetzen und wände decke
mit dem iphone
ich weiß gar nicht ob mir sehr viel
harte verwischt die grenze in der regel
ist ja das sozialnetz die schweiz
relativ dicht die normale kranke
versicherte dass alles funktioniert
haben das schweizer sozialsystem also
damit dass der schwarze peter wieder
zurück beim start
niemand will ein präjudiz schaffen alle
haben angst vor forderungen und die
betroffenen opfer was wünschen sie sich
aber heute klar dass die
verantwortlichen zum beispiel die
frühere schmidheiny also ich mit einigen
früheren demokratie sind das die ihre
verantwortung wahrnehmen und verrichtet
für entschädigungen wo ausgerichtet
werden einfach führen möchte und ich
danke es geht die juristische
verantwortung
es ist einfach ungenügend das höchste
moritz schweiz aber es gibt ganz klar
von mir ostsee soziale und ethische
verantwortung dass der schaden war
angerichtet hat dann einerseits anders
sieht sehr viel sehr viele jahrzehnte
lang umsatz gemacht hat die
millionenhöhe
für die stadt einen grund um angerichtet
hat also da und von mir ist dass ich
hoffe dass ich gesund
dann rennt sagen ich die für den dom
euro mit dem space ruhig kalt folgte
dekadenz in sap für den überfall gibt
kein schädigungen durch andere
krankenkassen lösung sind dass man die
natürlichste analyse computer wo ideen
um es im profi also geschützt sind
mit der trasse das mit dem ganzen
krankheitsprozess wo ich natürlich noch
andere probleme behoben sind außenhaut
problem mehr an tragen also die ganze
familie ist natürlich dort betroffen die
muster tragen dann volvo dem
mietgeschäft wo man geschafft hat
wenn du gut gelaufen abstrahlen und
zähle höchsten von heiligen und
rehabilitation meint die kids darauf
dass auch diesmal waren wir gar nicht
reden
die sind da und diesen teil des staates
und
ja das wetter wunsch dass ich 2009
gefallen war
[Musik]
das heißt es ist schon operiert
rehabilitation und 18
[Musik]
ja
verschmäht peter spiel wird weitergehen
die einzigen die ihre würde nirgendwo
hin abschieben können sind die opfer
eine gute nachricht gibt es jedoch
sowohl bei marcel jahn als auch bei
roland schwarz man hat man im moment
wenigstens keine neuen krebszellen mehr
entdeckt
[Musik]